hopeful um but i think the one thing
that was interesting from the president
was of seeing his vision of where he's
at we're in the state
he knew that this was very quickly and
can still
very quickly spread throughout this
country because the expectation of these
changes and i know there's governors out
there and citizens in other states
this is not just minnesota's problem we
need to own our problem and we need to
fix it but it's america's problem and i
think the president knows that
one more yeah governor i'm curious if
burning political capital means possibly
holding up
budget negotiations to insist on on
including these changes yeah i won't i
won't go into the hypotheticals of where
it's at what i am going to say is
i i guess in a wait and see because i
want to give people the benefit of the
doubt on this
um it's not going to be easy to avoid
this question this time it's not going
to be easy to walk away without doing
some changes
and we need to make sure that what we do
doesn't punish minnesotans doesn't make
it worse for minnesotans
but that if that change that minnesotans
are demanding is being held up by a few
individuals we'll figure out how to make
it so that those folks can help own that
and bring the fix but i'm in a place
right now
um i think like many that things can
work
that humanity does matter that people do
care about their neighbor
and the vast majority of people really
aren't interested in getting into
political fights about something that
that is so self-evident and needs to get
done so
um i won't say anything particular on
the strategy of doing it other than i'm
going to approach it with the sense of
good will and the belief that we're all
going to get there
because i don't know how you could be
sitting anywhere in minnesota today and
not see that something has to change and
that
kind of the precipice if you will of
where we found ourselves
um it's not as if that went away i i
would argue we maybe took one step back
from the ledge today
but we'll be right back on it again if
we don't do this so i want to thank you
all and
again extend my deepest sympathies to
the floyd family
and um and to those who
who this grief has come very close to
home to them so thank you all
mayor thank you